welcome back ivy league students who
have blamed Israel for the horrific
Hamas Terror attacks may be having a
tough time getting a job in the real
world billionaire hedge fund manager
Bill Amman is calling on Harvard to
release the names of the students who
signed onto a letter that said Israel is
entirely responsible for the Bloodshed
Amman writing in this tweet that he has
been asked by a number of CEOs if the
university would reveal their identities
to ensure that they won't hire them
looks like there's already been some con
quences the president of nyu's student
Bar Association sent a message to the
school that said Israel Bears full
responsibility for the terror attacks
while the New York Post reports that she
has lost a cushy job offer at the law
firm that was set to hire her well Greg
what about that well I mean the campus
is Ground Zero for this mind virus of
identity politics it really is a trade
school for vicarious terrorists who can
indulge in the splendors of the West
with their iPhone and every and Wi-Fi as
they egg on its own destruction I mean
we're seeing young people argue against
the existence of the very country they
live in it's and this is not about
limiting Free Speech it's about private
entities deciding not to employ the
ghouls who support beheading babies I
mean put let me put it this way in a
more direct way do Jewish parents or any
parents have a right to know about the
posting of a pro Hamas student that they
might consider as a babysitter would you
want that person around your family of
course not you have every right to not
hire somebody because of their beliefs
I'm so sad that I said permission to use
a metaphor and not analogy no that's all
right is that's Jess keep I just had to
say that to clear the record um Jessica
what about this it's the CEOs are
stepping up um you've got the Jonathan
nean of the CEO of uh sweet green
answering the call tweeting out that uh
he'd like to know the names I'm never
going to hire those people yeah I
actually know him from college College
um he went to Georgetown and I spent a
lot of time there my college boyfriend
was there and they were
friends that am tracking down from
brenmar um he's a great guy and I think
that people do have a right to this if
you can not get a job because you were
topless at a frat party or you smoked
pot and that was on social media then
this seems like it's actually a lot more
meaningful about how you see the world
what kind of employee you're going to be
what what you will add to the culture I
do think it's funny about this woman who
was um the head of the NYU student Bar
Association that she was going off to a
big law for she wasn't going to be a
public defender or something like that
she was going to a cushy job and get on
the corporate law track and make
millions of dollars which seems quite
the opposite of these kind of views to
espouse um yesterday I mentioned this I
think there's a tremendous education
Chasm that happens um about a lot of
issues you know Civics here in the US we
talk about it all the time but people
clearly don't understand the origin of
this conflict or what it actually means
and their teachers aren't doing a good
job explaining it to them which is a
shame some professors are speaking out
like Larry Summers and Jason Ferman at
Harvard as well released a whole
statement of his own saying I usually
don't get involved in this but I cannot
be silent about it judge I think the
interesting part of this is you have
these uh students coming out of these
prestigious Hoy pooy institutions who
now will find themselves
unemployable you know that will be
responsible for what they've said they
will be held accountable and that's why
you know the names of the CEOs should
also uh be identified in terms of the
ones who've indicated that they you know
kind of buy into this you know we're not
going to we're not going to reward this
kind of behavior but you know you have
to look at it in a couple of ways you
know there's such a thing as free speech
uh but there's also such a thing and I
think Harvard needs to look at at it
this way as leveraging har Harvard as
part of that free speech and what
they're doing is they're also bringing
down Harvard unless this is a place
where Harvard wants to be you know and
some young people are telling me that
they call it performative activism where
they literally don't really believe in
any of this stuff but they say it to get
along they say it you know to make sure
that they passed their grades and that
they don't have any problems at school
but now if there's accountability
they're going to have to start having a
moral core Dan well I would say a couple
things one I want the Amman wants the
names of all of them from Harvard
because he does want to hire them I want
their names because I never want to pay
a single taxpayer dollar towards their
student loan I'm just absolutely not
going to do that for any of them the
other thing is there are some University
presidents that are doing some great
work so Ben sass the former senator of
Nebraska is now at the University of
Florida his statement that he put out
today is one like if you're thinking of
where to send your kids to school this
might be a really good school to do it's
very clear he says he will uh respect
free expression but he is also going to
protect the Jewish students at the
school I guess they are anticipating
some big protests at some of these
schools coming up so if you want to just
moral Clarity from a university
president former Senator Ben SAS at the
University of Florida provided it there
you go I want Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now